good afternoon everybody my name is
Anders Hollis Burke and I'm here to talk
about what's new in typescript
typescript basically is about solving
this problem it's about making
JavaScript scale I'm sure it hasn't
escaped your attention that javascript
has seen tremendous growth in the last 5
5 or 10 years but in particular last 5
for variety of reasons you know like
JavaScript not just runs in the browser
but runs with node.js on the server and
runs in a variety of native modes on
devices like react native or cordova or
what have you on on phones and tablets
and really javascript is the only true
cross-platform game in town you know
even Java that was originally designed
to be cross-platform
isn't really cross-platform anymore so a
lot of developers are writing a lot of
apps in JavaScript but javascript was
never really designed to be a
large-scale application development
language it is a dynamic programming
language which means it has no type
system it was perhaps intended for you
know hundred or thousand line programs
and now we're writing like up to million
line programs and we all know that
programs that are that large take teams
they take scaling they take a bunch of
methodologies that we've already sorta
are familiar with in more grown-up
environments like say C sharp or or Java
so we're we were looking at this this
problem about five years ago about what
can we do to make JavaScript scale
better we basically thought that you
know the ideal solution to this problem
would be to add to JavaScript those
things that are missing for large scale
app development you know an alternative
strategy could have been let's create a
new language and just treat JavaScript
as the il of the web and just
cross-compile say script sharp or or
Java or what have you you know but but
you're never going to be best to breed
and you never
gonna get everyone happy if you're
targeting one ecosystem from another
ecosystem you want to be in the
ecosystem you want to be of the
ecosystem and so so with typescript we
basically set out to add these things
that are missing at the time when we
started five years ago javascript didn't
even have modules or classes and and so
that those were obviously targets but in
particular JavaScript doesn't have a
static type system and when you think
about what it is that powers the rich
development experiences that that
developers today are accustomed to like
things like code navigation statement
completion safe refactorings
what-have-you error checking before you
run your program all of that comes down
to having some ability for the IDE to
reason about the code you're writing and
that ability comes from having a static
type system so so typescript effectively
is about what's creating a statically
typed superset of JavaScript that then
compare compiles back to plain
JavaScript so in a sense typescript
starts with JavaScript and then we add
an optional static type system but then
when we compile all of the types go away
so you're sort of left in the in the
development phase of your program with
an elevated experience where you have a
more grown-up language but your code is
just JavaScript and it runs everywhere
that JavaScript runs now I said being
for the JavaScript community but we also
knew that it was very important to be up
the JavaScript community and we decided
to to write typescript in itself and
that means that it is effectively
written in JavaScript and that means
that our tool set runs anywhere in any
browser on any host and on any operating
system in fact if someone had told me
ten years ago Anders in five years
you're gonna be writing compilers in
JavaScript I got that that's a good one
but but here here we are
and it's it's quite amazing how far
these JavaScript runtimes have come and
how capable they are the chakra runtime
that we have an edge or the VA runtime
that Google has in Chrome or nodejs
it's amazing it's amazing what they can
do and we are indeed writing compilers
not just compilers we're writing entire
I des and development tools in in
JavaScript and they work beautifully as
you'll see and of course we set from the
onset we want this to be an open source
project we've been hosted on github now
for over three years we started out on
cope Lakes but but soon realized that we
got to go where the action is and move
to to github
that's our daily workflow the entire
team sits in a team room in Redmond but
but basically works on get up we take
lots of contributions from the community
and it's it's a fun way to work it
really is I'm writing more code these
days than than I ever have before now if
I have to sum up typescript really sort
of brings two key things to the table
key benefits one is great tools enabled
by static types and the other is the
ability to use features from the future
today which basically boils down to a
capability called transpilation let me
try to motivate that a little in in
JavaScript if you let's say you go back
say two years to May of 2015 this was
sort of the state of JavaScript back
then
Eckman script 2015 was just about to be
ratified yet on the server nodejs has
only just made it to es 5 and most
browsers didn't even support es 5 yet
and so there's this gap between what you
have to target in order to make your app
run and what you want to use as a
developer and that's what I call the
feature gap and that gap is actually
it's not it's not a one-time phenomenon
it's it's a thing that just sort of
continues to a
Syst here we are now two years later
we're about to ratify es 2017 yet on the
server nodejs has yet to get egg
Musgrove 2015 modules they're still
doing common Jas and you know we've only
just gotten to the point where you can
assume ignore squid v in in your browser
so so this gap continues to be there and
in fact it's it's a gap that will
probably always be there it's it's gonna
take a while for all these old Android
phones to to catch up with with the
latest and greatest and by the time they
do the latest and greatest will have
moved so in that gap we can fill this
gap by transpiling the latest and
greatest version of javascript down to
older targets and you'll see me demoing
that so so that is the they're sort of
those are the two key things that that
typescript brings to the table now in
this talk I'm gonna do a quick summary
of what it looks like to use typescript
and then we're gonna go into what what
have we done in the last year and where
where are we going with the product but
so bare baby there's a bunch of people
here who who may have not seen the
product in use at all and so we're just
gonna set that up a little bit um I'm
gonna switch to my demo machine here and
we're gonna write some code here so I'm
gonna fire up Visual Studio code which
I'm sure how many of you use Visual
Studio code just out of curiosity Wow
see your arms yeah wonderful Visual
Studio code is our open source IDE I am
proud to say that it is entirely written
in typescript so everything you see me
do here is written in typescript runs on
a JavaScript VM Visual Studio code also
uses the electron shell which basically
embeds WebKit and node and the v8
execution engine and allows you to build
desktop apps that way and that's what
we're looking at here and of course it
runs everywhere on Macs Linux etc okay I
just have a piece of JavaScript here
it's by inspection you could see it's a
function that sorts an array but
but who knows what it does because it
has no types there's nothing really that
says what's going on here we can see
there's a parameter called a but we
don't know anything about a and
therefore we don't know anything about
any of the things that are in here
they're just all of type any if I hover
we do know and we can give you statement
completion on there being a function
called sort by name but you can pass
anything you want to it then hey it's
JavaScript you know it's gonna it's
gonna blow up at some point but but not
yet now what if we could actually say
more about our intent well so so let me
first rename this to typescript so I'm
just gonna rename this file to main TS
and lo and behold nothing changes
because javascript is a our typescript
is a superset of JavaScript so anything
you can do in JavaScript you can do in
typescript but now you can do more
things specifically you can add types
that describe what you're intending to
do here so I'm gonna for example insert
an interface declaration of a person
which is a thing that has two properties
name and age and then I'm gonna say the
array here is actually a person array
and once I do that you see stuff starts
to light up all of a sudden down here if
we hover it says hey if the number five
is not an array yep that is true but so
let's try and pass an empty array and
now we're good there and then we get
some errors in here so so let's see what
how did we get that error so so a now is
of type person array and that means that
the slice method we know what it does
and it returns another person array so
that's the type of result and result
then has a sort method because it's an
array and sort gets you a callback
function that passes you two values that
must be persons we can infer and so we
can actually push the types from that
single annotation we have now strongly
typed everything in in this little
function and push the types everywhere
and so when I'm writing in here and I
say return X dot you'll see I get
statement completion on what the
properties are and since name is a
string we know there's a locale compare
method and
can pass to that why Dodd name and here
you just saw we found the error
I had misspelled local compare or locale
compare it's really III I had spelled
the local compare but that was wrong
now the checker can confine that error
for me
so so now you're gonna wonder well where
where did this information come from you
know how do you know that an array has
these methods so if I say a dot here all
the methods of array where did they come
from well we could try to say go to
definition on the slice method here I'll
just press f12 and that jumps us into a
file called Lib d dot TS this is what we
call a declaration file you could sort
of think of it as header files for the
web or header files for JavaScript it's
a file that contains all the type
information for the entire JavaScript
runtime library and the Dom this is a
very big file actually if we go to let's
see let's go to the bottom here 21 and a
half thousand lines now and these are
the 21 and a half thousand lines of type
declarations that as a JavaScript Avilla
you're supposed to know by by by heart
right because where else is it going to
come from someone you're typing your
JavaScript this is just stuff that you
either have to go look up or whatever
but now by writing it down and by having
a set of tools that understand it we can
actually serve it up in context and show
you all of this and we can use it to
check your code so the cool thing is
that we can provide the type information
after the fact we don't have to write
our code in typescript to get a type
check we can actually take plain old
JavaScript frameworks and then go write
declaration files for them and all of a
sudden poof you get a better experience
and of course the community has
obviously discovered that and and by now
the open-source community has collected
in excess of 3,000 declaration files for
all of the popular JavaScript frameworks
that are out there and we now
automatically package them up and make
them NPM packages
that are just installable and we'll see
that in later later later in the talk
here so let me try now to show you some
of the transportation capabilities so
let me for example try to use a feature
that got introduced in ignore script
2015 which is arrow functions and you'll
see that my editor allows me to do it we
understand what it is but but let's try
and figure out how that actually gets
compiled into JavaScript so I'll go back
here and then I'm gonna start or create
an init and in a configuration file for
typescript and then I'm gonna start the
compiler in watch mode and now the
compiler just sits and whenever I save
it automatically compiles my file into
into JavaScript so now let me try to
open in a different window here well put
Minjae s over here oops that's not what
I wanted to do what mean done to yes in
this window and we won't main dot J s
over there and here you see the same
code that I wrote but all of the types
have been erased you see that we're back
to what we sort of started out with
right but you also see that the arrow
function I broke got translated into a
regular function over here because our
compiled target is echo script v a Negra
script v does not support arrow
functions now let me try to add a a
class declaration also and let me try
and save my file and then you'll see the
watch mode the compiler and watch mode
behind the scenes automatically
recompiles the code and turns the class
into idiomatic Egmore script v that
basically is the code that you would
have to write before classes were
introduced and that you may have to
write if you want to run on something
that isn't yet egg Musgrave 2015
compliant now we can actually play with
this and we can bring up our config file
and then we can change the target that
we're compiling to to ignore script six
and let me just save the config file and
then you'll see that the output
immediately jumps and now it becomes a
prescriptive with the types erased right
so so basically there's this dial that
you can SEP 2
level you want from a single source base
you get to use the latest features but
you get to run on whatever target down
level target you you want okay so that
is a very quick introduction to some of
the features of typescript now let's try
to look at but real real-world use of
typescript looks like you I'm sure some
of you heard that a couple of years ago
we entered or more more like two and a
half years ago now we entered into a
partnership with the angular team at
Google they were working on angular 2
the next version of the angular
framework and they were talking about a
thing called atscript that was sort of
like a superset of typescript and we go
hey why don't we work together we can do
whatever features it is that you need
like they needed decorators and so we go
we can do decorator so so why don't you
why don't we go away and do that and we
did and then they took a look at it they
go wow this is great
and they decided to write angular 2 in
typescript and that's now been ongoing
for quite a while in fact they shipped
it and now they've also shipped angular
4 which was the next version and 4.1
which which introduced strict null
checking and whatever and so there's an
awful lot of code now in the wild
written in angular and let me let me try
and go find some of it here we'll go to
one site called angular Expo that is a
sort of an expo of a bunch of cool apps
written in angular there's a SoundCloud
client that was written in angular we
could try and run it here and it's sort
of a full-featured player for SoundCloud
I didn't hook up my sound here but it
actually does play the songs and it's
it's kind of cool now it also is
open-source it's hosted on github here's
the repository for for this app and I've
cloned that repo on this machine here so
so here it is and let's try to let's try
to fire up the idea here and take a look
at this code in fact well let's first
try to run it so I'm just going to npm
start
in here this comes with an NPM script
that automatically sets up a web pack
development server what you're seeing it
do here is since on the first start it
compiles and packages everything web
pack is basically this technology that
can take a whole bunch of Achra script
when a 15 modules and package them into
a single file that you then reference so
instead of having to download 900
modules you download one file and they
could also do tree shaking and do all
sorts of cool stuff so so if we built
the app here and now let me try go to
localhost 3000 and here you see a local
copy of the same app running and I
didn't really change anything but now
that we try and show you what the
workflow is like in in an app like this
you can see that that in the IDE here
you know we can navigate code it's a
modern app you know that has import
statements and uses classes and whatever
we can say go to definition of app
module you see that it uses decorators
here to to add a whole bunch of metadata
there's an app header component which is
the header band on by on my app and you
see in here there's like this
SoundCloud angular 2 title which is the
title that we said we see you up here so
we could try to modify that and just see
what happens with with the workflow so
let's try and say hello built here
instead and before I press save let me
let me do a little window rearranging
magic here so we can see all of the all
of the players in action here I'm gonna
put that window there and I'm gonna put
these windows over here and now I'm
gonna go back in the editor here and
let's see where was our change
oops right here and now I'm just going
to press ctrl s and you'll see what
happens here is webpack picks up on the
file change does an incremental
repackaging and then auto refresh is the
browser so thank you thank you so
so we know that we know by experience
that JavaScript developers like to be in
this mode of just edit and save and
immediately watch the changes but of
course we have a whole tooling pipeline
here that needs to get in the in the
picture but all of that has been
engineered so that
webpack can use our compiler as a
transpiler service that can transpile
the modules it can automatically be
packaged it can automatically refresh
the browser and you get exactly the same
experience that you know from playing
JavaScript but with a much higher level
programming language so that's what it
looks like to use angular another very
popular framework out there is react
from Facebook and and the associate
react native and I got a another little
example here that I want to bring up let
me just my machine went to sleep let me
login again let me switch to this
machine here which is a MacBook also
running Visual Studio code over here I
want to show you a react native app that
comes from a company called art C which
is a company that does a fine art
marketplace and they do all of their
development open source and they built a
whole bunch of cool open-source react
native components and i i have cloned a
repository of theirs for a demo project
called omission and and i'm running it
right here live in an iPhone emulator
let me try to bring that up and in here
you see that I'm on on the sort of the
home page of this app here and in this
home page is actually written as a react
component in fact it's this file home
dot TSX so so you're gonna wanna seeee
this what is this X me we know that T is
typescript well TSX is the typescript
version of JSX
and JSX is a
dialect of JavaScript it's it's
JavaScript but it also allows you to
embed JSX markup so basically you can
have code and markup in the same file
kind of like script text but but with
JavaScript on top instead if you will
and where markup is basically like
another form of expression element that
you can have so so let's look at what
that what that looks like in here if we
scroll down there's every every JSX
component has a render method and in
here you see how it just returns markup
and in this markup you can sort of
switch between markup and JavaScript
code very seamlessly so you see how you
can composite a ListView and then inside
the list where you can have some
JavaScript code that runs that then in
turn puts other markup in there and you
can even define markup components
yourself
so for example here is a search bar
component and we actually understand JSX
in typescript and not only do we
understand it but we understand the
types of the markup as well so you can
actually navigate on your markup so I
can say go to definition I'll press
function f12 on my search bar and it
jumps to the class called search bar
which implements that component and that
component in turn has a render method
that in a compositing fashion uses finer
grained markup and so it all sort of
breaks down that way now now in here I
could actually go refactor my my markup
so let me try to say function f2 and
call this one art finder instead and
notice that we changed the name of the
class here but if we go if we go back
oops let me go what is it we navigate
back well we can navigate back to the
home page here you'll see that it
changed over here as well so when you
refactor your markup if you actually
refactor not judge JavaScript but also
the markup which is which is pretty darn
cool
let me try to modify my search bar a
little bit you see that it has a the
text here says search for artist and
whatever we'll say hello build here and
let me just save and actually I should
say both files let me save this guy and
let me save this guy over here there we
go they did not reload nope okay I think
I should have saved both of them at the
same time anyway you get the idea here
that you you cannot reload your app here
and see the mark-up changes reflected in
but but that kind of broke for me though
sorry about that
anyway that's sort of a quick example of
[Music]
react native another framework that's
become very popular of late is a
framework called view Jas and I wanted
to show you sort of the workflow with
typescript and view as well so let me
try to go there UJ s okay and in here we
have a a small start wet pack on this
guy as well in watch mode keep that in
the background and then let me start
index dot HTML start the app just so you
can see what what this looks like it's a
little to-do MVC app written using view
so I can type in some stuff hello world
just and I can check them off but
there's a part of the app that doesn't
work this clear completed here has no
effect so let's go see what's going on
with that so we'll try to go back here
and fire up code and let's let's look at
a code here so this app starts in main
which is again modern app that you
webpack it has a to-do app dot view that
it imports here and this is an
interesting file here it's a dot view
file and a dot view file has both markup
and code in the same file in a template
section for the markup and then in a
script tag for the code and you could
also have CSS in there it could sort of
all be packaged together
now the reason this all works in here in
fact you see that when I hover over it
in here I actually get intellisense
instead and I'll get statement
completion and and so forth this works
because someone has built an extension
plugged it in and we plugged it into
vias code here with the tooling for view
and let me try to show you also as part
of this some of the work that we did in
typescript 2.3 is enables us to
understand the pattern use by view when
you're defining new components which
gives you a great authoring experience
you see that in here a component is
written by calling view dot extend and
then you pass in an object literal that
has a components property and a props
property and a data property and a
methods property and then view mongols
all of this together and makes an object
out of it and then when it calls methods
then this object inside those methods is
actually a combination of taking all of
that and making it into data properties
and computer properties so when I'm in
here and I say this dot you'll see that
we actually let me scroll up here so you
can see a little bit better I say this
dot for example to do's you see
statement completion here this
information actually came from this
object here returned by the data method
likewise create to-do came from the
methods that I had in my methods section
of my object literal so typescript 2.3
actually allows you to express that
mapping that occurs statically so we can
come
what this is gonna be in when you're
creating a component like this which is
which is not a simple thing to do but it
gives a great development experience for
for writing code in using view let's
just try to fix the little bug that the
App hat which is that I had commented
out this line here so we can say this
dot - duze equals this dot remaining and
we can just save this will automatically
repackage I can simply go back and
refresh here type in some stuff and then
try to say clear completed and now now
that works okay so those are lies it's a
whirlwind like three different
frameworks that you can use with
typescript and I think my point here is
a you get that modern JavaScript like
workflow but you have an elevated
experience where you get all the tooling
that that you're accustomed to from
grown up programming languages if you
will and be perhaps more subtly is that
typescript really is in a sense
Switzerland for frameworks you know we
don't we are not like Affinia ties with
a particular framework we really strive
very very hard to do a good job of any
of the popular frameworks out there
we're always on to watch because there's
a lot going on in this JavaScript
community new frameworks coming online
all the time and so view das that was
typescript 2.3 we reached out to Evan
you who's written that and like worked
with him to like make the development
experience even even better than it
already was okay let me go back to the
slides quickly and let's talk a little
bit about our release cadence and how we
go about developing typescript so in the
last eight months we have released four
times - OH - one - two - three I've put
up sort of like the two major features
from from each release here but but
there were a lot of new features that
happened this this is some of them and
then they didn't even fit on the slide
but the team boobs really quickly
we're actually now we have converged on
a two-month cadence and we ship we co
ship with Visual Studio code so whenever
they ship we ship a new version of
typescript
and we just snap whatever is done at the
time so instead of like trying to
determine oh we really want to get these
features in we get in whatever is we get
in and if you don't get in that train
then it gets into the next one the way
we work as a team is as I said we're all
on github we have a lot of tests that we
run in our repo we never accept poll
requests unless our fifty five thousand
tests pass and if it's a new feature it
has to come with new tests as well and
whatever pull requests go in they go
into typescript app next which you can
npm install and we actually have a large
portion of the community always running
on the nightly build because the quality
of the nightly build is so high that you
can get away with and that way you have
all the latest features but for us it
means that we're effectively perpetually
in beta there is really no such thing as
beta because beta beta happens every
night you know whenever whenever we do
the nightly build right and lots of
people pick it up we immediately hear
about issues if there are issues so so
in turn this allows us to move that much
faster so it's sort of this virtuous
cycle you know that just keeps on keeps
on going I wanted to show you some of
those new features that have gone into
typescript over the past eight months
and I'm gonna start by probably show by
showing you what I what I think is by
far the most impactful one whoops let me
switch to my demo machine here so in
typescript 2.0 we introduced a feature
called non nullable types which it's
actually quite remarkable if you think
about like well let me ask it this way
how many of you have ever had a
nullpointerexception right
isn't it remarkable that we still have
no pointer exceptions I mean like after
all these years we still we still battle
with with nulls Tony Hoare who's now
Microsoft Research who actually invented
know called it his 1 billion dollar
mistake in later in life because it
actually like he could document that it
at least cost a billion dollars in lost
work and whatever and now javascript
actually not only has null it also has
undefined so this is the two billion
dollar mistake in in in javascript and
so for typescript to oh one of our big
pushes was we're gonna we're gonna make
some progress on this problem now the
way we went about making that progress
was originally in typescript 100 all and
undefined were valid values of any type
so that meant like any string number
whatever you can always assign null or
undefined and that of course means that
it's very hard to track effects of null
and undefined if every type allows
allows null and undefined so the really
the crux of this work is to say we
introduced a new stricter checking mode
and in that mode null and undefined are
not valid values of any types other than
two new types one called null which has
the value no the only values no and one
called undefined whose only value is the
value undefined so their unit types
effectively and then we use Union types
to combine them so if you want a string
that can also be null then you say
string or null or a number that can also
be undefined or number or undefined you
get the you get the idea
okay that's it here's irse here's a
little piece of code I am gonna load up
my config file and then I'm gonna turn
on strict checking save that config file
and now when I go back here you'll see
that some errors appear that weren't
there before and these are all related
to nulls and undefined so let's try to
chase them down and see what we can do
to fix them first thing is we notice
that we get complaints about the
variable
count not being assigned before it is
used now what's what's going on here is
that the compiler is now performing what
we call control flow based type analysis
and that means it the compiler analyzes
all possible flows of control in your
code and then at every point where you
reference a variable it determines
whether at all of the possible preceding
code paths this variable has been
assigned and in fact it analyzes what
type the variable gets as a result of
all the thing all of the all of the code
that preceded you to that point right so
if there was a check for not equal to
null well then we know that we can
remove that from the type as we as we go
into that reference so so in a sense as
a side effect of the null and undefined
work we get definite assignment checking
and here we see you know we've
discovered that you didn't assigned a
count so now let me naively try to fix
that by saying count equals zero inside
the for loop which obviously is not what
I want to do but that causes this error
to go away but not that one because here
there's still a code path that gets me
there without getting rid of the
undefined so really the fix is more
likely to say equal to zero up here in
the in the definition of the variable
and in fact I don't even need to have a
type on it anymore I can just say equal
to 0 and then we infer that and now we
know that in all code paths were we're
good with that so that was one of the
issues now another issue here is this
complaint that object is possibly
undefined on my text parameter now text
this declared here to be an optional
parameter that's what this question mark
indicates and optional parameters can be
undefined if because that's what you get
if if the parameter wasn't passed to you
now I could fix the bug by saying oh no
it shouldn't be undefined well or it
shouldn't be optional but now I get an
error down here it's saying you can't
not pass text to me so but let's say I
do want it to be optional now I have to
somehow check whether I got a text
passed now one naive way I could do that
is I could say if text and surround this
whole thing
with a truth a check like that and that
takes care of the problem in here but
now something else happened up here
functional acts ending return statement
and return verses not include undefined
so basically the type checker has
concluded you could fall out the bottom
and that would cost you to return
undefined but you've said that you
return a number and a number can't be
undefined and so you got to do something
about that so I could say here return 0
and then that error would go away now
that's one way I could fix this I could
also instead say do sort of the bailout
style if not text return and then do the
rest and now we're good except well not
quite type undefined it's notice in
there you must return something so you
have to return 0 or something so you see
it's getting pretty hard to cheat this
type checker you know it's it's it's
really looking over your shoulder here
now of course probably the real way we
want to fix this is to surround it here
to say if texts do the for loop right ok
there we go so that leaves one bug in in
my code it says here that argument of
type string or null array is not
assignable to a string array well so
we're trying to pass a null but we said
that it was going to be an array of
strings so I guess we either have to get
rid of the null or we have to include it
in the type up here which we could do
now once we do that then another issue
now pops up this optic is possibly null
so now we got to go chase that one down
and say if line and and line dot length
nah blah blah blah now we're good so as
you can tell here this this is much much
deeper type checking than than you've
seen previously right and this really
does catch an awful lot of bugs in in in
your code so I would definitely
encourage you to use this new strict
null checking mode if you're not if not
using it already just for kicks let's
look at here do
a few more the effects of nulls and
undefined here's here's some crazy
functions like here's a function that
takes a string or a string array or null
or undefined and then some code here we
say if s so we're checking if s is
truthy and in here as expected we get a
it's either a string or a string array
we got rid up an all or undefined but
what do you think the type is down here
it's actually string or null or
undefined because the string could have
been empty and an empty string is false
E and so we actually might have a string
down here and the checker knows this
though but when you're writing the code
you probably forgot about that right I
mean so so these are like the gotchas
the javascript is full of gotchas but
the beauty of type checkers is the type
checkers don't care about screwy rules
as long as you put them in it can check
him and that's that's what it's what
it's doing here's that here's another
one right where if typeof s is object
what do you what do you think we get
here well we get string array or no what
well because typeof null is object in
JavaScript it's one of the mistakes that
that they made that they then decided
all typeof null really should be null
then they tried to fix it then that
broke a bunch of code well we can't do
that so there it is tombstone forever
you know like so so so therefore you
know but we know that it could still be
null in here if you have that kind of a
check right and down here we know that
null is gone here's another one if s
double equals undefined well s could be
no or undefined here because double
equals against null or undefined checks
for both of them but if it's triple
equals now it's only undefined that
could pass through here so all these
crazy little rules have been encoded and
the checker will just relentlessly point
it out to you it's like it gets really
irritating but but but but you know you
want you want to know this okay so
that's that's nulls the other I'd say
cool feature that we did in in
typescript 2.0
discriminated union types let me try to
show you those here's a classic peep
piece of object-oriented code with an
abstract class shape and then we have a
circle and a rectangle and a square and
day they have a radius and width and
height or size and there's a get area
function that computes the size and then
we make a circle compute the error so
OOP 101 now a lot of people tell me yeah
I heard about this typescript thing it
sounds really cool but you know what I I
write functional style code and now all
this stuff I don't need I don't need
loop you know it's like typescript is
all OOP it's like turning JavaScript
into c-sharp you're right no it's not at
all and I want to show you a different
way of writing code in in the same kind
of code in a more functional style and I
want to show you how types grave really
plays very very well in that space so
we're gonna get rid of the OOP here I'm
gonna get rid of all these classes and
instead what we're gonna put in is a
declaration that looks like this where
we say a shape is a thing that can look
that can have three different layouts
there's a kind property that's the
discriminant and the kind says what kind
of shape are you and you can see here
you can either circles rectangles or
squares and then if you're a circle you
have a radius and if your rectangle you
have a width and a height etcetera sader
pretty pretty easy to read actually what
enables this is a feature called literal
types and this is a type here circle
this is a type whose only value is the
string literal circle so the only thing
you could assign to kind for in here is
either circle or rectangle or square now
let me also try to show you a function
then that computes the area now in an
object-oriented solution I would have
had a tight coupling between my code and
my data you know I have code and data in
the same place right and that's
convenient in a because it allows me to
think of one thing but it actually
brings about some dissonance
in a lot of cases like one case for
example is persistence let's say I'm
writing a drawing program here we're
gonna save my shapes right well I just
want to convert them to Jason but I
can't convert classes to Jason because
what about my code so now I got to have
data transfer objects and I got to take
my class instances and put them into
Jason and then save that and then when I
read it I got to take the Jason back and
put it into classes and I have to have
these mapping layers and stuff lots of
stuff infrastructure right that that
doesn't really add anything to the
solution and the other thing is what if
someone gave me this object hierarchy
but it didn't have a get area function
in it our method in it what do I now do
I can't I can't modify this library so
now I got a right I get area function
but now it's sort of this coat smell of
instance of checks and what if I forget
one and blah blah blah and so so that
doesn't work so well either right but in
the functional style code and data have
are much more separated than here
I basically defined my data and I have
to find the entire domain I have said
shapes can either be one of these three
and that's it I know in a closed-ended
manner but what everything could be
would OOP this is another problem is I
don't there might be a fourth kind of
shape that I haven't heard of that no
one that someone derived another one
right and what do I do in my persistence
layer who's gonna check that I know how
to save that one as well right and so so
there are all these interesting problems
that come up so here is what it looks
like to do it in the functional style
now I can just say shape is kind : and
then let's say we want to have a circle
with a radius and you'll see that we can
actually give you statement completion
in here we know everything and then get
area just I'm just gonna pass a shape
like that now one thing now that that's
really cool is you'll note that my data
here is ready to go under wire it's just
data I could of Jason dot parse this
data I could just save it store it you
know so zero friction to to to save and
in fact if think about what if you were
writing a micro service right where you
get you get messages in Jason that have
a kind and a payload and then you go
that's what I'm writing here right so so
this is really a very very common
pattern now notice what happens here
when the type checker gets a hold of all
this stuff here in here I'm saying
switch shape kind let me hover over kind
and you'll see that we note time could
either be a circle or a rectangle or a
square at this point because we've Union
together your possible discriminants
right now when I write a switch
statement and I say case circle notice
in here that shape has been narrowed
down to that case and so we know exactly
that a shape in here is a circle and
therefore we can actually give your
statement completion and show you well
you're a circle and you have a radius
and nothing else in here and so all of
these features that that you know that
you're accustomed to continue to work
what's even more cool is that we sort of
know what what happens let's say I fight
I don't have rectangles covered and then
let's look at what is the type of shape
here and you'll see that well I handled
circles of squares in the switch
statement above so it's been narrowed
down to rectangle down here right so the
type checker actually follows all of
your flow and understand what's going on
now let me try to look at what happens
now what if I handle all of the cases
then shape gets narrowed down to a type
called never the checker knows you're
never gonna get here because you've
handled all the cases now we can
actually take advantage of that
interesting fact and we could introduce
a an assert function here called assert
never
it's a funny function it says here's a
function that takes an object whose type
should never occur and it's gonna throw
an exception saying something went wrong
now and now what I can do down here is I
can say assert never of shape and get
rid of that throw there now if now see
what happens here is as long as
everything is good we're going to have
an ever
here and that's gonna passed a check but
what if we forget one I forgot about
rectangles a checker comes right up and
tells me hey you didn't handle
rectangles
now that's exhaustive nest ekang if you
if some of you have done functional
programming I mean this looks an awful
lot like a DTS and pattern matching and
exhaustive nest egg and all of these
patterns that you use in camel or
f-sharp or or what have you but it's all
done in JavaScript and it's all done
with no new syntax either this is a very
cool way to program this is actually how
the typescript compiler is written
internally that's we don't have any
classes at all in a compiler the type
checker is one big function it's a very
big function it's like xx I don't know
1250 some thousand lines or but and all
of our syntax trees and whatever it's
all declared in this manner and it's a
cool way to work so and typescript
really Grox it too so so I highly
recommend you you look at that and don't
think of it just as an OOP exercise
that's another thing you can do but this
truly is a hybrid language that allows
you to do both ok the other thing I'm
gonna try and show you now is types
checking of JavaScript here's an empty
directory I'm gonna npm install jQuery
because I'm gonna write some jQuery I'm
I'm a retro kind of a dude and then I'm
gonna npm install lo - there we go
and then I'm gonna fire up a shield
studio code and I'm gonna add a main Jas
there we go and now I'm good to go and
I'm gonna type dollar dot and boom
statement completion where did that come
from
um I'm in JavaScript here how do you
know anything about dollar but it well
we know what NPM modules you have
installed
we can go consult no doubt of our
modules and then we can go to NPM and
see if there are type definitions
available for those modules and if there
are we can suck them down an auto
provision your IDE with the types that
correspond to the modules that you're
using even though you haven't said
anything about typescript you're just
programming in JavaScript all of a
sudden we can give you this great
experience based on all of that type
information for example we also know
about low - yes there's type information
available for low - so now I can say
under bar dot filter pass an array of
numbers like that and now we can start
flowing the type so in the callback here
we know that X is gonna be a number and
so we know what methods are available on
number and so without you doing anything
you actually get a lot of the benefits
and this is what's cool about typescript
being a superset of JavaScript is that
javascript is just typescript with no
type annotations but that doesn't mean
the checker can't check it can check a
lot and in fact as we thought about this
we sort of realized that hey what if we
had a type checking mode that was more
of a conservative checking mode you know
when we're checking typescript we're
basically if we're unsure about
something we're gonna whine and give you
an error and make you fix it just so we
can be absolutely certain that we've
checked everything but what if we had a
mode that was sort of the opposite where
well if it could be true great but if we
for sure know this is wrong why don't we
let you know about it and the checker
can do that and it can actually do a
really great job of it particularly on
modern JavaScript that's written with
modules and classes because we can
statically analyze the structure of that
so so let me show you what that looks
like in real life let me fire up on a
project here called get up crawl up
which is an open source project that
that we just grabbed from github it
seduced by internally by Microsoft open
so it doesn't really matter what it is
just a bunch of JavaScript and I'm just
gonna open all the files here there we
go and lo and behold what I've done here
the only thing I did after getting this
this cloning this repo is I added a
config file where I turn on check J s
and that basically tells the compiler
hey give it a shot
check that JavaScript and see what you
can what you can find out and and we
actually find out a lot of stuff now
this I should also say this is a snap in
time of a particular repo where the
programmers later fix the bugs we
actually we actually grabbed a copy
about a month later for another demo and
whoa what what happened two bugs are
gone oh well they found the bugs
themselves the hard way right but so we
have to go back to that previous commit
where the bugs were there so so that's
what you're seeing here here we go first
one is in here we're calling a method
and it's saying then parameters don't
match well let's say go to definition
notice that statement completion works
and well this thing takes no parameters
and they're passing it an argument that
doesn't make sense we should we should
tell you something about that right so
so we do so let's not pass an argument
there here's another one same thing
we're passing two arguments function
takes one argument God knows what's
gonna happen to the other but let's
let's make it take another argument and
there that that goes away
here's here's something else that's sort
of suspect we're newing up an error
object and then we're starting to
properties on to it but error objects
don't have underbar types and URL bar
but of course you might mean to do this
so you'll note that we have a little
light bulb there and if I if I pop up
the suggestion it says oh just ignore
this error message and notice how we put
a little comment on the line above that
says ignore errors on the next line and
so you can sort of go through and just
tell yeah okay that's fine I've looked a
dab one I don't I don't mind that one
we're good we're good
there and they go away here's another
one new requests on payload except if we
go to request there is no payload in
here but we could add a payload it's
actually good practice to always
initialize your properties in the
constructor because the VM will do
better layout that way and then that
error goes away same thing here
there simply isn't an event its method
on so I don't know how this code could
I've ever run well oh it's code in a
callback
I guess that callback never got called
right so so I guess they don't have test
coverage of this particular one so we'll
just get rid of that here's another one
it says there's no type property on
request well one of these suggestions
that we have here if I control dot is
just go initialize one so we'll just
simply have it add and now if I say go
to definition you'll see this line of
code that our code fix inserted so you
can actually just ask for the fix if you
will here's another one that's similar
to that I'm just gonna say yep go
initialize this in the constructor if we
go to the constructor you see that we
added another one I can keep going dude
there's there's maybe one that I think
is interesting here moment diff and it
says there's no diff then I went and
looked at the type declarations and know
there is a diff but but it but it's on
the result of calling moment not on you
know so that one took me a little while
to think through but this is the kind of
stuff that that type checkers can find
because because for a moment we actually
could find the type declaration files
for that by Auto provisioning and then
checking against that and for all of the
other stuff you saw in the classes it's
because we can analyze the static layout
so there's a whole bunch of cool stuff
we can do even without you doing
anything to your code but then of course
since typescript is a superset you can
ease into it and start writing type
annotations and then we could do even
better but we're really very focused on
reducing that glideslope into into
typescript and allowing you to stop and
and actually just still have JavaScript
all right let me go back and quickly hop
through the last few slides type system
I mean my point really is at the bottom
you can look at a slides afterwards but
it's this type system is both object or
in ant functional and generic and
gradual and structural and it's a very
interesting type system it does a lot of
stuff that I haven't seen any type
systems do before it's a lot of fun to
work on tooling you saw me use Visual
Studio code of course you can use big
visual studio but you can also use a
variety of IDs out there we actually
have great support for all of these IDs
and the reason we do is that we've
engineered typescript to be this service
that you can use from your editor plugin
so you don't have to understand anything
you just have to tell us about all the
edits that happen and then we can cough
up all of the answers from this outer
process node server that that we run
that talks to your to your extension
typescript adoption we are growing leaps
and bounds we're up to more than four
million downloads per month now on NPM
we recently made it into the top 20
programming languages in red monks
survey we're up there now as number 17
with Scala and Swift so it's it's it's
great to see that the community is
really picking up on on typescript at
this point one that particularly made me
happy is that we are now in the top
three most loved programming languages
on stackoverflow right behind thank you
behind small talk and and rust one
morning I had the other day I was
reading my coffee and whoa look at this
article here someone at the engineering
group at at slack was writing about how
they spent six months rewriting all of
their JavaScript apps to typescript and
they loved it
and so so you know and lots of other
companies are doing it and in fact a lot
of the JavaScript frameworks are using
typescript and honestly this is perhaps
the most
hortence lie because if anyone knows
JavaScript and all of the issues and the
JavaScript community it's the people
writing the frameworks and look at how
many of them are using typescript in
their day to day development and that
really warms my heart that's it pretty
much for me here I encourage you to go
visit typescript Lane org where which
just got a revamp we have a whole bunch
of new getting started guides that are
really cool that allows you to see how
you get started with angular react or
view or what have you come talk to us on
the issue tracker on github the whole
team is there every day it's is where we
live and we also have a booth downstairs
come talk to us I'm gonna pop down there
as much as I can but we have Daniel and
Boden down there great guys to talk to
about about typescript so that's it for
me thanks sir thanks for coming and
thanks for using our product thank you
[Applause]